das ist so nein nein nein nein wenn sie
nicht gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
herzlich willkommen zu sein wie oft man
kann leute bevor wir anfangen muss ich
erst mal sagen ich könnt eure augen
leute das in den letzten tagen woche auf
diesem kanal ist bombastisch gewesen die
videos gefallen weil ich gut das gibt
mir mehr viel spaß videos für euch zu
machen und wenn ich euch auch zum
beispiel wird irgendwas einzusetzen
wieder kommen direkt gefühlt hunderte
vorschläge und das macht mich richtig
vorstellen mal danke sagen nachdem das
geklärt haben können heute wieder
anfangen werden ihr habt mir wieder
diverse videos eingestellt habe die ich
reagieren sollte und 1 davon
das ist ein video was ich nicht erwartet
habe aber jetzt ist es da ja mist das
video business geht heißt schnitzeljagd
sahne ist mein leben
ja gut das wars dann wieder mal komplett
[Musik]
das ist also die erste szene dieses
videos er muss dazu noch sagen dass es
auch eine rtl2 produktion ist leider der
kanal heißt family stories unfall die
sich wie ich mich jetzt auch gerade
fragen was der rtl2 darf schon wieder
verpufft hat hilft ein blick in die
beschreibung die dokusoap zeigt familien
und ihre geschichten erzählt wie eltern
kinder und freunde mit unerwarteten
situationen umgehen und am ende zu einer
positiven lösung gelangen bestimmt immer
sagen nicht mal eine andere sehr
bekannte hatte er zwei serie vor augen
halte hilfen ja dann kann ich mir auf
jeden fall sehr sicher sein dass es
hierbei definitiv nur darum geht etwas
zu dokumentieren und keinesfalls der
sinn der ganzen sendung ist einfach nur
jede scheiße darzustellen
ok moment wird schon mal kurz ihren
einkaufswagen leute wir erkennen
dazwischen ein klein bisschen gemüse
einer tiefkühlpizza und sage ich nichts
mehr einen gigantischen berg sahne
schlecht und jetzt wird's genau zwei
möglichkeiten wir das ganze laufen kann
leute entweder die frau ist
professionelle konditorin und ihr job
ist es kuchen zu machen für die man
natürlich sehr viel sahne braucht oder
aber die alter volk nackt und braucht
das ganze für sich selbst was wir zu
sein als wir da mit dem einkaufswagen
junge ecke kam
das ist einfach nur an ich wollte so
schnell wie möglich ein und habe ihr
geholfen da das ding hier die treppe
hoch ganz kurz heute ist das der sinn
von einkaufswagen
ich habe mir bisher gedacht nun geht es
im supermarkt haut dann so einen kleinen
chip in den einkaufswagen rein geht rein
geht raus wird die sachen ins auto oder
ausfahrt er war aber eben nicht dass man
den einkaufswagen mitnimmt und dann in
den drei zehnten stock zu sich nach oben
trägt
aber wer weiß vielleicht zu den
transport von sahne besondere regelungen
natürlich muss ich da was unternehmen
ich mein ich habe noch mehrere mieter im
haus
das ist einmal ihr vermieter und ich
glaube für mich das an der stelle ist
sauer weil er denkt dass diese frau
einsame problem hat unter aller sau die
da über schmerzen beschwerden klang
atemstörungen und sagt die eine sagte zu
mir ist glaubt schon sie etwas mit der
lunge und wollte zum arzt gehen aber das
ist einmal versteht sich ganz warum also
was war in diesem keller war das sammeln
wie man das sagen
die frau hatte mag ja scheinbar so hat
die sachen im keller gelagert und dann
verstehen wir lassen oder wie und dann
denken leute sie haben wegen der
abgelaufenen serie atemprobleme
was passiert hier
so führen wir sie wissen wer ich bin ja
wir wollen bitte rein dann sieht das
dann keller bei ihnen aus dem keller
kommen sie damit dass man eine zeuge
geht ganz kurz erst mal 18 passiert hier
und dann an zweiter stelle was ist das
für ein aufzug von den vermietern
was hat er für sachen an so geht er
gerade in kriegsgebieten mit nachteilen
verseuchtes wasser reinigen muss oder
als beiden hier mit dem mit diesem
blauen anzügen erstanden da habe ich
echt gedacht die müssten wir einen
halben stadtteil evakuieren dass sie
irgendwo chemiewerk in die luft gegangen
ist ja meine rede wo ist in der story
dieser folge der bio war der angriff der
sohn anzug gerechtfertigt ich möchte mir
gerne die wohnung ansehen und den keller
die entsorgung das zahlen sie ich habe
schon die container bestellt das geht so
ihren lassen das kann ich ihnen sagt ok
erst richtig merkt also die für mich
einfach mal sorgen um seine wohnung weil
angeblich aber auch nur angeblich diese
frau auf der rechten seite hier einsam
ein problem hat das ist das allein schon
wieder fit ist dann werde er seinen sehr
guten vortrag macht die frau im
hintergrund einfach gar nichts
wer denkt sich so wisst ihr was wenn ich
schon bei rtl2 mitspieler okay und ich
kriege nur das geld für meine paar
zeilen die ich im skript habe da macht
es wahrscheinlich man könne keine
reaktion kein gesichtsausdruck keine
emotionen irgendwo vorberaten ich möchte
mir die wohnung ansehen und den keller
die entschuldigung dass zahlen sie ich
habe schon die container bestellt das
geht zu ihren lassen klar also doch ich
glaube es aber im land schnell aus
okay da hatte sie jetzt wieder ein
einstieg ist sie kurz mal aus dem aus
dem offline modus im stromsparmodus
zurückgekommen weil die kamera also
genau auf die darauf gerichtet konnten
somit in der mitte von bild und sie
dabei keine recht
und den keller die entschuldigung dass
zahlen sie ich habe schon die container
bestellt das geht zu ihren lassen oder
so oder so die fernbedienung also wie es
hier schon riecht und jetzt lassen wir
die wohnung besichtigt mit der vor
wochen darauf zusammen acht meter lagen
natürlich die macht ja die verwaltung
für mich hier sie hat mich angerufen er
kann aber auch nicht noch mal erleben
ist natürlich auch schon verständlich
dass man als vermieter bei einem etwas
größeren sahne problem der eigenen
mieter bisschen ausrastet aber er hat ja
wirklich mal eine tonlage
wir können nicht einmal reden scheint ja
das kann doch wohl nicht wahr sein
profil auch wie sieht das denn hier aus
ist das schweinestall nummer zwei war
ich habe mir ja schon vieles vorgestellt
aber das ist so hammer hat wird also wir
haben nicht so viel gesehen gerade
diesem schrott aber wir sehen hier schon
mal das wichtigste instrument einer
modernen jungen frau die keine sahne
ganzen lebensmittelreste katzentisch
ich weiß nicht wo die katze ball hinkel
das ist so abartig wie kann die kapsel
feiert gab ich das so über sie geredet
wird die kannst du denkst auch gerade so
was kann ich dafür dass meine heiteren
einfach alle krank ist leider kein grund
mich an rtl2 serie einzuziehen ist die
bude sauber und in einer woche ist die
grundreinigung drin und jetzt hören sie
auf mir ein foto pendels ihn ruhig mal
die haben sie mich hier zu pendeln so
eine reaktion alter beschreiten sie
seien so wie auch macht man dies als
gutes los mit dir
und sie welche wirken soll das haben
sondern es bringt will sie nach
eckbällen wir sind hypnotisieren leute
wenn ich irgendwann im alltag oder
einfach
ein fehler gemacht hat und dafür eine
strafe bekommen sollte einfach pendelt
das problem einfach weg was sollen die
spielt hier mit dem pendel sie sollen
sich immer die wohnung kümmern die
sauber machen jetzt und ihre nichte
spieler hat geworden also das ist ja
wohl das allerletzte
nehmen sie als bitte das pendel
unterseite bei ihm in dem fall nicht zu
viel gebracht habe ich auch was da los
war wahrscheinlich war das pendel kaputt
die seite verliert natürlich kein beweis
dafür das pendel nicht wirksam sind ich
war ich habe ja noch eine soziale ader
so dann komme ich in eine woche wider
dann ist die stubenrein ich glaube
sowieso das ist dieses faule müsste das
sowieso nicht schafft in einem kommentar
alte bekannte sind beide voll von diesen
dämon besessen also da muss ich echt
auch noch was tun
[Musik]
ja okay von dämonen besessen hätte das
pendel zu dämonen vertreibungen da habe
ich mal die fakten liegen ja auch ganz
klar da wenn der vermieter hat sich
darüber beschwert dass seine wohnung
nicht sauber ist ist er logischerweise
von dämonen besessen
[Musik]
ich habs jetzt die ganze zeit in schutz
genommen aber jetzt hier ab dem punkt
muss ich sagen verliert diese langsam
sympathiepunkte ich muss sagen der sich
so ein schrott sahnehäubchen straight in
mund setzt schon ein bisschen arbeit
genug
die stimmung rauße räuchern ist los mit
der sv ried
das ist nicht normal die große frage
dabei ist heute wie kann man so viele
dachschäden auf einmal haben geht jan
sahne schaden der in pendelt schaden
die jetzt scheinbar auch ein reicher
schaden so oft kann man kinder gerade
vom wickeltisch fallen lassen
[Musik]
ist das wahr sie hat scheint man hier
ein bündel stroh ein bündel stroh und
dieses bündel stroh will sie jetzt
scheinbar zur vertreibung der dämonen
und selbstständig auf der schlechten
stimmung mit shisha cola anzünden
das shisha kohle möchte von allen guten
geistern verlassen
dieser blick jetzt gerade sind die
absolute härte alter sie hat
offensichtlich eine an der waffe die
vermieter weg pendelt schlechte stimmung
heraus räuchern und könnte ich mache den
einen oder anderen schuss sahne
zwischendurch im privaten sowie dem
komischen zweiter jemand guckt sie
kritischer andern dann bekommt er nur
zurück
das kann nicht der bilder so es nicht
text
weißt du was du okay weil jemand er ist
jetzt wirklich außen das macht urlaub
gerade mein gehalt ist jetzt wirklich
voll im urlaubs modus fühlt sich
wirklich sagen als hätte mein gehirn
einfach gesagt die arbeit gern mit ihr
zusammen aber auf die chance die wir
bereits east habe ich gar keinen bock
ich werde das noch mal alles ausräuchern
mit feature kohle und strom scheinbar
nicht genug jetzt wird es zeit für alles
klar
bis jetzt ganz verrückt geworden oder
was er in dem ich so uncut es muss sein
[Applaus]
warum warum schickt
willst du jetzt hat häschen geworden
oder was schüssel oder gerade mal auf
meine medien erhalten das hat ihn
spontan mallorca urlaub mal eben auf
drei wochen verlängert nachdem es
mittlerweile auch spät genug und ich hab
dann auch keine lust mehr in diesem
chaos zu kochen und dann habe ich hinter
beschlossen mit ihr irgendwie essen zu
gehen aber ganz kurz er ist doch ihr
freund oder warum bist du noch bei der
regatta soll wenn diese auf 100 prozent
melden dass verrücktheit gestört als
level ist er trotzdem noch so auf 70
prozent
er macht nicht selten muss aber er ist
immer noch bei ihr werden mittlerweile
auch spät genug und ich hab dann auch
keine lust mehr in diesem chaos zu
kochen und dann habe ich hinter
beschlossen mit ihr irgendwie essen zu
gehen dann leider auch als die falsche
entscheidung an der steller liga
sie hat natürlich hau ab solange noch
kannst
[Musik]
keiner steht da ok also schauen wir
jetzt in dem laden in den
riesenschnitzel wer das riesen schütze
auf ist krieg zum sonst ich weiß nicht
warum aber ich habe auch bei der sache
kein gutes gefühl
[Musik]
okay sie hatte schon eine ganze menge
aufgehört ich habe bisschen vorsprung
ist schon eine ganze menge aufgegessen
scheinbar kann sie das letzte stück
fleisch nicht mehr essen
sie macht jetzt irgendwas damit und ich
habe kein kein gutes gefühl dabei leute
alles klar
freilich nein nein nein nein das ist das
geht ganz ehrlich sorry das gebe ich
noch nicht was zur hölle haben wir da
schon wieder gesehen
wir müssen so bereits klar leute ich
glaube dieser art von videos mit dieser
wunderbaren person gibt es noch mehr
wenn ihr wollt dass man dann auch mal
anschauen dann schreibt mir das gerne
die kommentare ich glaube ich erst mal
genug für heute check hier drüben noch
einen für euch vorgeschlagen das video
ab und bleibe stark
ja leider stark